what we're going to do in this video
some examples converting between leaders
and milliliters and just as a reminder
milli means one thousandth so a
milliliter is one thousandth of a liter
or another way to think about it one
liter is one thousand milliliters so
given that how many milliliters would
seven liters be pause the video and
think about that well if one liter is
one thousand milliliters then seven
liters would be seven thousand
milliliters and what about 18 liters
pause the video and think about it well
that would be 18,000 18,000 milliliters
so ever however many liters you've got
it would be a thousand times as many
milliliters because each milliliter is
one thousandth of a liter let's do some
more examples so here says blank
milliliters equals 15 liters pause the
video again see if you can figure this
out well remember every liter is a
thousand milliliters so 15 liters would
be 15 thousand milliliters remember if
you have a smaller unit and here you're
smaller by a factor of a thousand the
number that you would need of it to have
the same as the large unit would be
larger so you have a smaller unit so you
have a larger number here let's do one
more example compare using greater than
less than or equal to so nine liters how
does that compare to ninety milliliters
pause this video and try to answer it
for yourself
well how many milliliters is nine liters
nine liters is the same thing as nine
thousand milliliters and nine thousand
milliliters is clearly greater than
ninety milliliters so what you want to
do in a problem like this is convert
both to milliliters nine thousand
milliliters that's what nine liters is
that's nine thousand milliliters that's
going to be greater than ninety
milliliters